well certainly Boris Johnson was a
friend of Ukraine was he not how do they
feel now that he is stepping down van
impristaiku is ambassador of Ukraine to
the United Kingdom and he is with us now
hi good to see you thank you what'd you
like to say to Boris Johnson this
morning
I have to say that he was very popular
that's just to give you how popular he
was you know ukrainians just
successfully accumulated enough money to
cut up to buy a couple of drones the
Turkish made drones crowdfunding the
next idea to Crown fund the Prime
Minister Johnson to us
[Laughter]
um some might say you're welcome to him
but others might not
um but is it him or is it the fact that
he was the figurehead for the British
people sure you know I was explaining
the ukrainians that Boris Johnson is not
ordering some small village at the
sister Shore to raise the Ukrainian flag
or the rest of the cabinet or the
opposition itself no because that's
that's what many people are doing and
what is just disappearing this effort
but as a foreign secretary he was in
Ukraine a couple of times he knew the
nation
he understand the gravity of situation
and he was he managed to accumulate only
to get together with this effort and
bring Ukraine what we needed at the time
the most and what was the relationship
like between President zielinski and
prime minister Johnson
this this people call it chemistry was
there
so the Buddhist says you remember he
went to Ukraine twice he was the first
leader to come and it was really really
hot in Ukraine in the cave especially so
he added this personality to the whole
deal and Ukraine has just loved his uh
appearance and the way he was he was
doing he the way he was talking to our
Parliament that was appreciated I hope
the next prime minister will be the same
okay what was what was it about Boris
Johnson and president zielinski that
made them hit it off so much the extent
where president zelensky actually
addressed the British Parliament didn't
he and vice versa am I right no because
certainly he did he he's actually
addressed parliaments all around the
world but I think ours is one of the
first yes the parliament here was the
first and I believe that it was not just
this feeling of novelty but also the
special treatment zelinsky receives here
he was very happy at this particular
moment to address the Parliament and the
same was done your premise was the first
one to address our Parliament so you
know the UK was always on the Forefront
a bit further than everybody else
sometimes it annoyed some of the bigger
partners and helped us to get what we
wanted at the time so are you perhaps a
little disappointed as ukrainians that
Ben Wallace is just at the defense
secretary has decided not to stand at
the same time would like him to be where
he is because he's very instrumental
there I understand the complexity of
your politics in turn the politics I
understand why some some future Prime
Ministers are taking the decisions they
are but we need somebody like Ben on a
place of of Secretary of Defense as well
and when you look at our internal
politics here in the United Kingdom and
you see that 11 people are suddenly
running to be prime minister potentially
12 by lunchtime today does it give you a
wry smile not really what it gives me as
you know all the Ambassador is very
excited to follow the news to to the BET
who will be next what it gives us also
that the system is very different now a
case presidents set for that some time
they made mistakes they make great moves
but they know at least they know how
long they will be in position in your
the situation is much more fluent you
have a lot of female um politicians
don't you in Ukraine they tend to get
the job done
they're trying their best as males as
well and we have very new Parliament and
don't forget that our Parliament was an
idea of zelinski that none of these
people were MPS before this is social
experiment I I would call it so they
brought the you know the use of the
enthusiasm and they likened some of the
of the experience what sort of guidance
and advice might you offer those that
would be prime minister coming from a
Ukrainian perspective
our perspective Ukrainian is to have
maximum of the support at the same time
we understand how important is to
explain to your own people why you're
doing that it's not because you're a
personality not because you're calling
zillion's kitchen every second day and
you have this you know understanding but
you have to explain why you have to
sacrifice something why the prices are
growing up maybe it's not because like
why the hunger in the world is not
because we're in Ukraine because Russia
came to to make this world Ukraine so
there is some explanation is needed and
when people know and take the informant
decision that's what we expect from from
UK at least talk to me about the
situation in Ukraine at the moment both
as far as the war is concerned ongoing
war and also the desperate attempts to
try to get the grain out of Ukraine to
feed the world
the grain is is difficult part because
it's time sensitive we're feeding at
least 400 million people around the
globe not just us at the same time we
don't want to be seeing somebody who is
producing something very valuable
commodity which can be taken out of us
it's still part of our economy it's
still part of our survival when we ask
for assistance we also wanted to to buy
our future in a decent way like
everybody in the around the world there
is at least 23 million of of the grains
tons of the grains in a thousand parts
parts of Ukraine and the problem is that
the new Harvest is coming
it will be on the level 60 70 million
tons we don't have anywhere to put it so
you know instead of wasting it we have
to understand how we can use it all of
us together
I read that it takes two years to take a
Year's worth of grain out via land so
you need Odessa to be a functioning Port
how are you going to do that to put you
in perspective I had a very nice lady
businesswoman came to us and told us she
has 18 trucks to help you create with
the effort and I told you we need four
or five million tracks to have the job
done so it was very good attempt but
it's not helping we have to have ships
to be able to do so what we what we
managed already to achieve we when we
feed this Snake Island so-called which
will stay in just in front of our ports
well and the young man that let the
Russians know what he thought about them
yeah I know they're not heavy but we're
happy when they are not so it allows us
to you know to start creating this
Corridor the protective one for the
ships go all the way to the at least to
the remaining import Deport of constanza
where we can start exporting things but
ever since very expensive to do this way
it's
different way when they used to do what
you could do is start to remove the
mines from the Black Sea there on the
port of Odessa and allow the ships to
come in but that is a dangerous game for
you guys sure we have to be sure that
they're not they're not coming through
the same safe Channel which will create
demand in it and Russians also mind the
half of the sea now when we're receiving
more and more into ship Rockets which
allows us not just seeing their their
shoes but repel them from the Ukrainian
Shores that would allow us to open up
the disease but at the same time as we
speak we're also using the rails the the
trains the trucks everything we can to
the the degrees on the world markets do
you think there's tens of millions of
tons of grain that's about to be
harvested will go to waste hopefully not
this time because we were more prepared
but we don't have the silos to put them
in the first place even before we were
able to to ship them out and naturally
because of the war the the size of our
Harvest will be shorter because where
the the lenses you know reduced this is
the outcomes of the world one of those
and as far as the war is concerned were
led to believe that Russia is winning
the war at the moment would you agree
we're not saying that they're winning
they're pushing with lots and lots of
people lost lots of armor but when we
received this long reaching artillery
and raucous this is the change in the
tide we have to you know to survive
couple of more months to be able to have
more people for example we're training
here almost 10 000 of ukrainians
Troopers
in the UK
what do you want the next British prime
minister to do as soon as they take
office I understand there will be
different persons there is no doubt
about that and ukrainians also fear that
there will be there will be change in
the policy policy towards Ukraine at the
same time I expect some conditions I'm
sure that will be the case but we will
see how it will be how it will be done
some of the moves of the Prime Minister
was were quite unorthodox at that time
when he started this we hope that this
is more planned sort of stage when we
know what we need we know where is it we
know what we have to do and we have to
do together okay
um and you won't tell me who you want to
be the next prime minister no I don't
it's good to talk to you thank you very
much indeed Mr Ambassador thank you